he's so good at that and around the red
this guy's got a good job yes finally
the dump goes down nicely duck in but I
know he's the guy that's gonna beat you
Jerome
Wow it had the smarts to initiate the
contact on dumb bar nice little kiss as
you would say cause a little smooch but
they lift the big guys gives them an
opportunity to get home to see them try
to get into that defense off the ball to
inspiration like this right here nobody
paid attention on the weak side a little
more and that guy to keep Virginia up
three he's down to five to shoot what
he's on the board with his first points
he shows it and took it back and then
exploded
for
Spencer oh just thanks at home bangs at
home that seven lead changes and again
another impressive pulled down by
McLemore and Harper Reese
28:25 scored a see who's broke out
though right out of the gate really
stepping up a lot more pressure this is
when you get back cuts or open look look
at this get back sir you can't press
them in the half court
McLemore the top score on the first half
nobody cutting it's the first five and a
half
DeAndre hunter showing his defensive
ability their confrontations interesting
though that difficult looking shot
[Applause]
does it his way between baskets
announcer Romer and a huge first-half a
little out of control to take it away by
Harper he may have taken that extra step
ahead to Daddy who is able to lay it in
for the tie of 36 mentally this is a
revved up team naruko boys on the go he
takes an item now with six to shoot
those who can elevate short clock right
here to Rome this takes his time and
off-balance one hand and a beautiful
touch right there that's the shot that
Tony Pacific wouldn't bubby draw up in a
timeout this is an important force I in
the back of Purifoy he's driving it up
for two more down to a one-point game
wait committee a different personality
it's a little more motion right on the
baseline here's that little flex and pin
down a little action Brown wants it I
don't know where that's been the fight
of his battle to on that three-pointer
is pal God contested
the outfits of men pay the price but how
about this little pass by the little guy
number two in your program right now
number one of the arts of the Albarn
followers big push attacked the rim at
the other end now for Virginia the
second one two four eight four point
lead two possession game here for
Virginia and the gun for two right away
they don't have a speed guy to go to the
rim not a hurry now shot from the water
goes down the one with 6.5 McQuaid steps
in shut off back outside recovering way
takes it with 1 on the clock buries that
will take care of that fact line deepmax
a pretty good step out make that so we
expected tonight over comes over one
citerior passing whew what a bead it was
by golfers a little of their motion now
screened rescreen keep busy there you go
there's moose time another guy who can
make shots outside that's the same since
he's come back
we're sorry aggravated an injury in a
way drops from downtown for Francis and
the lead
that's the boiler wasn't going to read
the point on it's a little clearer route
for begin at all thanks huh
that's goings is on the defensive end
for both sides as culper wants to get on
track to start the second s but gives it
up we're ready but one to shoot that's a
three
got the basket and a foul pull enough to
cover in the back instead of best
earlier Jim Edwards and Frances have
been a great help side defense sure
Owens is up to it tonight to take those
kinds of passes useable Virginia wants
to turnovers getting out on the break
great decision right here
Tyrone takes his time makes the deep
inside big key for the slam dunk and
what a tremendous finish inside save the
genius pace right now and of course tied
to Rome leading this team scoring
Edwards pushes to the head top of the
key he wants it hey gets that he can mix
but I'm so well when he's in New York
particularly Columbia
with this team on his shooting to go in
there and see his dance Botha play and
stand on one of my favorite towns this
hoje there here's hunter to get the
first one yeses first from the field
we're both the boys you say Lok Lak now
with great hunter does that set up his
ability to use the physique and attack
the rip stay at home should you roam
with to oneness shoot he likes those
short clucks wasn't an easy finish right
there either but God well it's this bike
he were ready
down the one up to the star the big 12
Player of the Year on the ACC's top
defender use on the lefthand corbin
curve was stepping up in the right time
using the left
[Music]
gotta go fast Jerome gives it up farside
[Applause]
goodness with 12 seconds remaining
hunter continues with this great play
the second half knock down that corner
three and what happens a lot of great
defense
sometimes over helps a good reaction to
the dribble you're looking to help your
partner out but a wide-open knock down
jumper then bounce throw looking for
something to the corner culvert shot we
have overtime for the national
championship you stop on the defensive
end
he makes the clean block we got overtime
opportunity where they kicked him for
his ring it wasn't like that that really
fueled that comeback only had one
scholarship offer from Air Force the way
he has played here at the Final Four
nice little jab squares up the ball a
little bit they really do they've been
able to get through the cracks to show
zone and get to that man hit the shot
they had the regulation does it again
scored Arbenz six to one in the last
seven seconds and I with that three and
then the three free throws in you know
this is a tribute to character you see
the emotion on the faces of the Virginia
players going than that bench
they've got ki-duk sit down eight points
in front
facing adversities over and over our
kids and climbing the mountain eight
seconds
final seconds flying out end of a
fabulous tournament rebound into the
hands of hunter
and Virginia with the all the time
turnaround title